[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja Hayali
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend
krankenhausreform klingt nicht sexy ist
nicht sexy sie ist aber notwendig und
und das ist der Grund warum wir heute
einen vertiefenden Blick darauf werfen
auch wichtig für uns alle denn jeder von
uns will sich doch gut versorgt wissen
insbesondere wenn es zu einem Notfall
kommt niemand möchte dann erstmal 50 km
durch die Walachei fahren um behandelt
oder im Ernstfall sogar gerettet zu
werden dazu könnte es aber vermehrt
kommen wenn weitere Krankenhäuser
zusammengelegt werden das ist nur ein
Aspekt der krankenhausreform die Karl
Lauterbach also der
Bundesgesundheitsminister auch heute auf
dem deutschen Ärztetag quasi dem
Parlament der Ärzteschaft in Essen
verteidigt hat Britta Spiekermann
die warnow-klinik in Bützow
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern 70 Betten
verteilt auf vier Abteilungen ein recht
typisches Beispiel für die Versorgung
auf dem Land klein und viel im Angebot
die Klinik steht seit Jahren finanziell
unter Druck die Chefärztin für Innere
Medizin war vorher am Uniklinikum
Hamburg sie weiß wie wichtig ihre Arbeit
hier auf dem Land ist ich sehe
insbesondere auch durch meine eigene
Erfahrungen großes Ungleichgewicht in
der ärztlichen Versorgung in
Metropolregion versus in dünn
besiedelten ländlichen Gebieten und das
ist sicherlich großes Problem es geht
ums Überleben die Klinik müsse auf links
gedreht werden sagt der ohne Zweifel
ehrgeizige Geschäftsführer mehr
Digitalisierung mehr Vernetzung mehr
Spezialisierung nur raus aus den roten
Zahlen eine Million Euro - jedes Jahr
die Herausforderung kleiner Häuser ist
dass die Strukturvorgaben das was sie
vorhalten müssen um überhaupt für den
Pat ienten aber zu dürfen werden immer
weiter hochgesetzt
und dann verteilen sich kaufmännisch
gesprochen solche Fixkosten natürlich an
einer kleinen Klinik auf weniger Fälle
auf weniger Patienten das Dilemma ist
bekannt Ärztetag in Essen wie sieht die
Kliniklandschaft der Zukunft aus Karl
Lauterbach hat schon vor Monaten eine
Reform angekündigt er selbst nennt sie
eine Revolution Krankenhäuser sollen in
drei Kategorien eingestuft werden ganz
oben die Universitätsmedizin die besser
ausgestattet werden soll dann die
spezialisierten Fachkrankenhäuser und
zumeist in ländlichen Gebieten die
Grundversorgung werden vor allem die
kleinen Kliniken von dieser Revolution
hinweg gerissen
also wenn die Reform nicht kommt dann
wird es tatsächlich viele Krankenhäuser
geben die nicht überleben die
Krankenhäuser sind jetzt von der
Insolvenz zum Teil bedroht auch
Krankenhäuser die wir dringend brauchen
diese Krankenhäuser können wir schützen
können wir retten aber wie Bund und
Länder sind sich durchaus uneinig
Krankenhausplanung sei ihre Sache und
nicht jedes Bundesministers aber rechnen
sich tatsächlich die vielen kleinen
Krankenhäuser in Deutschland wir gehen
davon aus dass wir in den nächsten zehn
Jahren durch die krankenhausreform aber
auch durch die Situation des
Fachkräftemangels ein Stück weit
Konzentration brauchen insofern rechnen
wir durchaus mit 10 bis 20 Prozent
weniger Krankenhaus Standorten in den
nächsten zehn Jahren die Warnung Klinik
will nicht warten bis die Reform
beschlossen ist das Krankenhaus
spezialisiert sich schon jetzt auf die
Orthopädie fraglich ist ob die
Grundversorgung für alle Patienten
künftig darunter leiden wird
und und Länder streiten also noch über
diverse Inhalte der Reformhaus Baden bzw
umsetzen müssen es dann die die in den
Krankenhäusern arbeiten wie birgitär
jung sie Chefärztin für Innere Medizin
und als ärztliche Direktorin
verantwortlich für die Strategien einen
schönen guten Abend
guten Abend Frau Harley nicht alle
machen alles das ist ja die Idee statt
Quantität gebündelte Qualität ist denn
das sinnvoll sowohl für Sie als Ärztin
aber auch für mich als Patientin
als ich denke das ist durchaus sinnvoll
zu konzentrieren das ist etwas was wir
ja auch schon länger praktizieren das
heißt man konkret gesprochen es gibt ein
Krankenhaus ah neben ist eine besondere
Leistung angeboten wird und es gibt ein
Krankenhaus B in dem eine andere
Leistung hoch spezialisiert angeboten
wird und diese Synergieeffekte muss man
dann nutzen das heißt jemand hat viel
Erfahrung in einer Operationsmethode der
andere macht sie vielleicht nur fünf Mal
im Jahr ich glaube da liegt es auf der
Hand diese Expertise zu bündeln das
unterstützen die Ärzte durchaus und
damit auch den Gedanken der Krankenhaus
Reform das hier ein wichtiger Gedanke
hinterlegt dass diese Qualität zu
fördern statt Quantität jetzt sagen Sie
energieeffekte davon spricht der
Bundesgesundheitsminister ja auch und
nennt drei Level noch mal vielleicht in
kurz Level 1 da geht es dann im Grund
und regelversorger Level 2 sind dann
eher spezialisierte Kliniken und Level 3
sind dann
Universitätskliniken die alles machen
also auch Transplantation und Beatmung
also hat Carlotta Bach da eine gute Idee
in dem Grunde nach ist es sicherlich
eine gute Idee zu sagen wir Verhalten
wir halten verschiedene
Versorgungsstufen vor dem Grund sagt es
nach das heißt der Grund- und
regelversorger muss das grow der
Patienten versorgen allerdings ist
dieses ein sehr starres System so wie er
das im Moment vorschlägt das heißt es
ist ein ganz bestimmte Leistungsgruppen
nein das ist noch ein weiteres System
hinterlegt dass nur bestimmte
Erkrankungen oder Techniken in den
einzelnen Leveln angeboten werden das
heißt ein konkret gesprochen also ich
bin jetzt an einem Grund und
regelversorger tätig müsste ein Patient
mit einer Leistung die ich zukünftig
nicht mehr anbieten darf dann in das
nächste Level Krankenhaus verlegen und
müsste im Grunde um diese Leistung die
ich bis dato immer hervorragend mit gute
Expertise angeboten habe weiterreichen
jetzt machen sie doch aber sie sind
natürlich kritisch ja aber sie sind ja
in Nordrhein-Westfalen also in Bonn und
da gibt es ja sowas ähnliches sie nennen
es halt Leistungsgruppen was ist denn
der Unterschied
also ich denke das ist ein ganz
wichtiger Aspekt den sie ansprechen in
Nordrhein-Westfalen haben wir ja schon
uns etwas früher auf den Weg gemacht und
eine Krankenhausplanung oder Minister
Laumann auf den Weg gebracht die jetzt
gerade in der konkreten Umsetzung ist
das heißt Herr Laumann und die ihn
beratenden haben in den
Versorgungsgebieten den Bedarf geprüft
sie haben geprüft was wird wirklich
gebraucht in welchen Regionen und damit
auch in den ländlichen Regionen und es
ist definiert worden das
Leistungsgruppen definiert werden also
Innere medizinere Medizin ist ein
Bereich eine Leistungsgruppe wird dann
noch weiter untergliedert und damit
kommt eine Spezialisierung aber das ist
nicht so klar an bestimmte
level-krankenhäuser gebunden sondern an
die einzelnen Häuser die erstmal nicht
weiter kategorisiert werden das ist ein
sehr komplexes System was aber
wesentlich mehr Möglichkeiten zulässt
einfach auch die jetzigen Häuser in
Experten auszubilden aber nicht diese
ganze grundsätzliche Umstrukturierung
erfordert weil sie offenbar zu starr
erscheint in ihren Augen jetzt könnte
man ja sagen Nordrhein-Westfalen mag das
vielleicht sogar auch sinnvoll sein auch
das was Karl Lauterbach sagt aufgrund
der Dichte der Städte also der
Ballungsgebiete aber im ländlichen Raum
wird das doch nicht funktionieren
funktioniert denn da ihr Konzept
also ich denke also ihr Konzept ist
sozusagen als aus ärztlicher Sicht
würden wir denken dass es besser
funktionieren würde weil genau diese
Grund- und regelversorger dann in den
ländlichen Bereichen noch existieren
könnten und weiterhin diese Leistungen
anbieten könnten indem ich nenne es
jetzt mal Lauterbach Konzept gibt es ja
auch Krankenhäuser die vorgesehen sind
die eigentlich nur so bessere
Fachkliniken sind wo es keine
Notaufnahmen gibt und genau diese
Notaufnahmen braucht es ja in der
ländlichen Region um die Erstversorgung
machen zu können und das wäre in vielen
Bereichen dann nicht mehr möglich das
heißt wir laufen da wirklich auf eine
Versorgungslücke hin wo die Patienten eh
schon sehr weit zum Arzt fahren müssen
vor der jungen letztendlich geht es ja
allen darum Kosten zu sparen und und
insbesondere auch die Versorgung zu
verbessern vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz
was braucht es denn weil sie sind ja
Praktikerin sie erleben das alles jeden
Tag und sehen das alles jeden Tag was
braucht es denn ihrer Meinung nach
ich glaube im Krankenhaus sehen wir wir
sind ja alle jetzt mühsam durch die
corona-pandemie gekommen und haben
gedacht danach wird das alles besser
aber wir haben ein enormen
Fachkräftemangel das heißt im Alltag
während wir leistungsfähig wenn wir
wirklich ausreichend Personal haben wir
müssen Stationen schließen und darüber
weil wir einfach nicht genug
Pflegekräfte beispielsweise haben im
ländlichen Raum auch zum Teil nicht nur
noch Ärzte und müssen deswegen
Operationen absagen müssen wichtige
Untersuchungen verschieben und damit
auch den Patienten gar nicht die
qualitätsvolle Medizin mehr anbieten
können die wir haben wir haben eine
enorme Bürokratie die wir anbieten
müssen die Schwestern und auch die Ärzte
verbringen ein Großteil des Tages an den
Schreibtischen um zu dokumentieren und
wirklich nicht am Patienten zu sein und
da das was wir eigentlich unter Medizin
verstehen anzubringen zu können ich
glaube da haben wir auch einen ganz
großen Nachbesserungsbedarf und das
würde für mich auch eine Reform im
Gesundheitssystem bedeuten sagt Birgit
Herr Jung praktiziert in Bonn vielen
Herz lichen Dank für dieses Gespräch und
was wir mitnehmen es ist auf jeden Fall
noch jede Menge zu tun vielen Dank
vielen Dank auch
ja alarmierend auch anderes Thema immer
mehr Kinder können zum Ende der
Grundschulzeit nicht richtig lesen
Gundula ja ein Viertel aller Kinder hat
zum Ende der Grundschulzeit so große
Schwächen beim lesen dass der weitere
schulverlauf belastet ist eine
internationale Grundschule
leseuntersuchung zeigt mittlerweile
erreichen 25 Prozent aller Grundschule
nicht das Mindestniveau das für die
Anforderungen der weiteren Schulzeit
nötig wäre vor sieben Jahren betrug der
Anteil noch knapp
19%. die Studie bestätigt zudem Kinder
aus privilegierten Elternhäusern haben
bessere Chancen auf Bildungserfolge
Fazit Bildungsgerechtigkeit bleibe eine
Herausforderung dazu später um 0:30 Uhr
im heute journal Update ein Interview
mit der Studienleiterin der
bildungsforscherin Megalodon
dreieinhalb Jahre nach dem Juwelen
Diebstahl aus dem Grünen Gewölbe in
Dresden sind fünf junge Männer zu
mehrjährigen Haftstrafen verurteilt
worden die 24 bis 29-Jährigen gehören
zum Berliner remo-clan sie erhielten
Haftstrafen von bis zu 6 Jahren und drei
Monaten vergleichsweise milde Urteile
infolge von Absprachen Gegenleistung
Rückgabe der Beute und Geständnisse beim
letzten Stopp ihrer Reise durch die
Golfregion hat sich
bundesaußenministerin bärburg in Katar
über
Arbeitnehmerrechte dort informiert Thema
der morgigen Gespräche mit der
politischen Führung des Emirates werden
auch die Handelsbeziehungen sein zuvor
hatte bärburg in Saudi-Arabien eine
international vermittelte Waffenruhe für
den Jemen gefordert unter Einbeziehung
aller Akteure des Krieges
die Zahl der weltweit gerichtlich
angeordneten Hinrichtungen ist weiter
angestiegen die
Menschenrechtsorganisation
dokumentierte für das vergangene Jahr
883 offiziell vollstreckte Todesstrafen
in 20 Ländern der Anstieg ist vor allem
auf Hinrichtungen in Iran
Saudi-Arabien und Ägypten zurückzuführen
dazu kämen noch tausende geheimgehaltene
Hinrichtungen mutmaßlich vor allem in
China Nordkorea und Vietnam
das Russlands Krieg in der Ukraine auch
ein Informationskrieg ist das wissen wir
alle mittlerweile daher sind Aussagen
von beiden Seiten ja auch immer mit
Vorsicht zu genießen in der Regel war es
bisher oft so dass die eine Seite etwas
behauptet hat was die andere dann
dementierte aktuell meldet die Ukraine
Erfolge rund um die strategisch wichtige
Stadt bachmut um die seit Monaten ja
gekämpft wird und Russland widerspricht
dieses Mal nicht russische Soldaten
gehen sogar noch einen Schritt weiter
und sprechen von Chaos in den eigenen
Reihen ist aber vielleicht auch das
Taktik oder stecken die Russen wirklich
in einer Art Mausefalle wie es ein
Befehlshaber der ukrainischen
Streitkräfte heute formulierte Tim
Krüger weiß mehr
der Kommandeur mit Spitznamen Kurt
beobachtet das Livebild der Drohne
seiner Einheit irgendwo über der Front
und bachmut aus Sicherheitsgründen muss
vieles unkenntlich bleiben sie versuchen
eine identifizierte russische Stellung
mit der Artillerie am Boden zu treffen
der Kampf um die Stadt ist in eine neue
Phase getreten erstmals haben die
ukrainischen Truppen Gelände
zurückerobert Situation
die Situation ist angespannt aber stabil
wir versuchen den Feind von den Flanken
der Stadt zu vertreiben
der Plan ist es die russischen Truppen
zu bezahlen
es ist ein erbitterter Kampf im Quartier
der Einheit stellen sie sogenannte
Kamikaze Drohnen mit Sprengstoff her um
die Söldnertruppe Wagner und die
reguläre russische Armee zu attackieren
alles ist zerstört und Schuld an diesem
Bild ist Russland
dieses Dorf kann nicht wieder aufgebaut
werden
es gibt keine Infrastruktur nichts alles
ist ruiniert
und keiner weiß genau wie viele Menschen
getötet oder verwundet wurden im Kampf
um bachmut ein gepanzertes Fahrzeug
bringt einen Soldaten der an der Front
durch Schrapnelle verletzt wurde zu
einem evakuierungs- und Erste Hilfe
Punkt er wird stabilisiert für den
Weitertransport
wir haben ihn versorgt und Infusionen
gegeben
24 Stunden dauert eine Schicht der
Helferinnen und Helfer hier immer wieder
ist entfernt der gefechtslamm zu hören
aber immerhin rund 95% der Verwundeten
könnten sie retten sagen sie der
28-Jährige ehor ist seit einem halben
Jahr im Einsatz jeder Handgriff musste
sitzen Emotionen kann er sich nicht
leisten
ich mache nur meinen Job und ich weiß
was ich zu tun habe jeder hat seine
Aufgabe in diesem Krieg erfüllen
das ist auch für die medizinischen
Helfer und Helferinnen gefährlich denn
die evakuierungspunkte selbst können
Ziel von Angriffen werden ich träume wie
jeder in der Armee davon zu meiner
Familie zurückzukehren leben und gesund
für den Verbündeten Soldaten ist der
Krieg wohl vorbei ein Ende im Kampf um
bachmut ist nicht abzusehen
bachmut ist ja seit Monaten der
Schwerpunkt der Kämpfer aber auch die
Hauptstadt ist in diesem Monat schon
acht Mal zum Ziel russischer
Luftangriffe geworden heute früh war es
besonders heftig 18 Raketen und sechs
Kamikaze Drohnen sollen auf Kiew
gefeuert worden sein aber ohne
durchschlagenden Erfolg denn ein
Großteil soll abgefangen worden sein
darunter auch mehrere hyperschallraketen
vom Typ kimscheid die der Kreml ja gerne
als unbesiegbare Wunderwaffe feiert
abgefangen übrigens mit Flugabwehrsystem
die von Deutschland und den USA
geliefert wurden und jetzt soll wieder
etwas geliefert werden jedenfalls wenn
es nach der Ukraine geht Kampfjets und
da kommt jetzt plötzlich tatsächlich
Bewegung rein
er kam um Danke zu sagen und um mir zu
bitten Berlin Paris London egal wo wurde
mir selenski in den letzten Tagen
auftauchte sein Wunsch nach kämpft jetzt
dürfte niemanden überrascht haben seine
Prognose vielleicht schon
wir wollen eine Kampfjet Koalition
bilden und ich bin da sehr
zuversichtlich
gibt es da etwa Bewegung als der
US-Präsident Ende Januar gefragt wurde
ob sein Land F16 Kampfjets an die
Ukraine der liefere waren die Antwort
kurz
nein was für ein Kontrast gestern London
der britische Premier dieselbe Frage
noch keine Zusage aber schon nah dran
wir werden ein wichtiger Teil der
staatenkoalition sein die mir und der
Ukraine diese Unterstützung gewährt aber
es wird keine einfache Sache
worum geht es der Ukraine und moderne
westliche F16 Kampfjets als Ergänzung
zur eigenen Flugabwehr die viele
russische Eingriffe abfängt aber längst
nicht alle jetzt nutzt aber zum Beispiel
aktuell die russische Luftwaffe derzeit
Bomben und schmeißt die ab über der
Reichweite der Flugabwehr der Ukraine
und hier können dann eben Kampfjet zum
Einsatz kommen die sind auch dafür
gebaut dass man gegnerische Flugzeuge
eben abfangen oder abschießen kann
verschiedene NATO-Staaten haben F16 Jets
im Bestand von den USA bis zu den
Niederlanden anders als bei den
Kampfpanzern ist ein Land diesmal aus
dem Schneider
Deutschland hat diese Maschine nicht hat
sie auch nie geflogen und deswegen
können wir an dieser Stelle wenig machen
mit Ausnahme wir können Flugplätze zur
Verfügung stellen vielleicht technisches
Know-how aber mehr haben wir mit der F16
nichts zu tun und so müssen sich vor
allem andere diese Frage stellen wie
groß ist das Risiko einer Eskalation
theoretisch könnte die Ukraine mit F16
Jets selbst weit entfernte Ziele
angreifen nicht nur die Krim auch
hunderte Kilometer in russisches
Staatsgebiet hineinfliegen realistisch
nein sagt ein ehemaliger NATO Strategie
hat sich bis jetzt sehr zurückgehalten
schon die bisherigen Systeme hätten sie
ja sehr viel offensiver spektakulärer
einsetzen können haben das aber nicht
getan nach einem Jahr der Zusammenarbeit
können wir der Ukraine vertrauen
keine westlichen Kampfjets das letzte
Tabu der militärischen Unterstützung es
fällt am Abend am Rande des Treffens des
Europarates verkünden der britische
Premier sunak und seine niederländischer
Kollege Marc rütte man wolle eine
internationale Koalition schmieden Ziel
die Ukraine mit F16 Kampfjets zu
beliefern
das dürfte in den nächsten Tagen eine
spannende Diskussion werden das was
putin will ist Zerstörung die Zerstörung
der Ukraine und der ukrainischen
Identität letzteres kann man schlecht
messen aber den Rest also so etwas wie
die Zerstörung von Krankenhäusern
Wohnblöcken landwirtschaftlich genutzten
Böden das kann man schon dokumentieren
und genau das soll jetzt auch passieren
in einem schadensregister das ist
jedenfalls das Bestreben des Europarates
nicht zu verwechseln mit dem
Europäischen Rat dem Europarat gehören
46 Staaten an darunter alle 27
Mitgliedstaaten der EU aber
beispielsweise auch Großbritannien die
Türkei die Ukraine oder aber auch
Aserbaidschan Russland gehört seit
vergangenem Jahr nicht mehr dazu heute
traf man sich wieder dutzende Staats-
und Regierungschefs waren dabei bei
diesem vierten Treffen unter anderem
auch Bundeskanzler Scholz denn es geht
um weit mehr als nur um ein
schadensregister Isabel Schäfers aus
Island
normalerweise trägt die isländische
Polizei keine Waffen doch heute muss
alles besonders sicher sein in Reykjavik
nach 18 Jahren kommen die Staats- und
Regierungschefs des Europarates wieder
zusammen der Grund für dieses seltene
Treffen ein Mitglied des Europarates hat
ein anderes angegriffen
unsere Botschaft ist klar Solidarität
mit der Ukraine wir sollten die Ukraine
unterstützen die Ukraine sollte diesen
Krieg gewinnen die Beziehungen zwischen
Russland und dem Europarat waren immer
schwierig sogar bis große Vorbehalte als
Russland 1996 Mitglied werden wollte
mitten im ersten Tschetschenienkrieg
es gibt gute Gründe Russland nicht
ausgerechnet jetzt aufzunehmen während
seine Regierung einen brutalen und
unmenschlichen Krieg führt
Russland durfte dennoch beitreten und
blieb 26 Jahre dabei bis ein neuer Krieg
der Angriff auf die Ukraine zum
Ausschluss Russlands führte ein bisher
einmaliger Vorgang der Europarat muss
sich nun also neu denken
dass sich in Russland an die
demokratische autoritäre Entwicklung
durchsetzen konnten spricht nicht gegen
den Europarat
sondern dafür dass wir unsere
gemeinsamen Regeln künftig noch ernster
nehmen dass wir sie als Frühwarnsystem
verstehen für den Friedens Erhalt in
Europa der Charlie die Herausforderung
für unsere gemeinsamen Werte wächst und
jetzt ist der Zeitpunkt gekommen sich zu
wehren ganz konkret wird der Europarat
ein internationales schadensregister für
die Ukraine schaffen dort sollen die von
Russland verursachten Schäden
dokumentiert werden das könnte die
Grundlage sein für künftige
Gerichtsverfahren gegen Russland und für
Reparationszahlungen
mit diesem Register und dem Kampf gegen
die Straflosigkeit unterstützen wir die
Ukraine das ist der Kern der Mission des
Europarates er ist es der die
demokratische und juristische Sicherheit
unseres Kontinents gewährleistet
der ukrainische Präsident selenski ist
zugeschaltet sein Premierminister
vertritt die Ukraine vor Ort
das Register ist ein erster Schritt
damit die Ukraine für all die Schäden
und Groll Taten durch Russland
entschädigt werden kann
heute in Reykjavik geht es vor allem um
die Ukraine aber auch darum sich selbst
zu versichern dass der Europarat noch
immer seine Bedeutung erfüllt als Hüter
der Menschenrechte und
Rechtsstaatlichkeit in Europa
und wir machen jetzt weiter mit Gundula
und mit der Nachricht aus der Welt der
Wirtschaft als erstes Mitglied des
VW-Konzern Vorstandes hat der frühere
audi-Chef Stadler ein Geständnis
abgelegt in dem Betrugsprozess um den
dieselskandal vor dem Landgericht
München Frank Widmann was bedeutet das
Geständnis für ihn und für den Konzern
ja für ihn selbst Stadler wird das
Gericht nach 168 Verhandlungstagen
voraussichtlich als verurteilter
Straftäter verlassen jedoch als freier
Mann dank seines Geständnisses manch
einer sagt Stadler ist dabei noch gut
weggekommen für die direkte Manipulation
der Motoren konnte er nicht
verantwortlich gemacht werden wohl aber
dafür dass er den Verkauf der Autos in
Europa habe weiterlaufen lassen Stadler
ließ über seine Anwältin einen Text von
ihm verlesen indem er unter anderem
zugab Zitat das ist ein Mehr an
erforderlicher Sorgfalt bedurft hätte
Zitat Ende
im Gegensatz zu Stadler dürfte der
dieselskandal für Audi noch lange nicht
vorbei sein viel spricht dafür dass die
Staatsanwaltschaft München 2 eine
weitere Anklage gegen weitere ex-audi
Vorstände vorlegen wird Stichwort
Schadenersatz können sich Betroffene des
dieselskandals nun Hoffnung auf
Entschädigung machen ja wenn man sich
unter Juristen umhört herrscht doch
weitestgehend Einigkeit dass dieses
Geständnis von Stadler heute sehr wohl
ein Beleg dafür sei dass Manager bis in
die Konzernspitze hinein von der
Manipulation gewusst hätten also ja den
nach können sich Betroffene Hoffnung
machen
Schadensersatzansprüche haben weit über
50.000 VW und Audi Kunden in
Einzelklagen bestellt dazu kommen
zahlreiche Ansprüche die über eine
sogenannte
musterfeststellungsklage gebündelt
worden
vielen Dank
der langjährige Nachrichtensprecher im
DDR-Fernsehen Klaus Feldmann ist im
Alter von 87 Jahren in Berlin gestorben
fällt man war das Gesicht der aktuellen
Kamera guten Abend meine Damen und
Herren guten Abend meine gelernte
Buchdrucker und Journalist präsentierte
die aktuelle Kamera von
1961 bis 1989 er veröffentlichte mehrere
Bücher und erzählte darin auch von
Versprechern die nie hätten passieren
dürfen wie statt Polit
pilotbüro der SED
kann kann zum ersten Mal haben die
Filmfestspiele eine Präsidentin zudem
sind so viele Regisseurinnen wie noch
nie im Wettbewerb und gleichzeitig
reißen auch im sechsten Jahr nach den
Enthüllungen rund um metoo die
Diskussionen darum nicht ab dass das
Festival mit einem Film eröffnet wird in
dem Johnny Depp mitspielt dürfte sein
übriges dazu beigetragen haben in den
USA gilt der Schauspieler seit den
gewaltvorwürfen als unbesetzbar aber was
soll's sobald der rote Teppich
ausgerollt wird geht es hauptsächlich um
Rollen und Filme von der Eröffnung
Thomas beide
bevor der erste Film gezeigt wurde
feierte das Festival von cann am Abend
an in der Großen der Branche Michael
Douglas bekam die goldene ehrenpalme für
sein Lebenswerk
das bedeutet mir so viel denn es gibt
zwar hunderte Filmfestivals aber es gibt
nur ein kann
auch er wurde von den 2500 Gästen sehr
freundlich begrüßt Johnny Depp spielt im
Eröffnungsfilm der Regisseurin my when
Johny einem Kostümfilm eine Hauptrolle
als Ludwig der 15
Depp spricht in der französischen
Liebesgeschichte durchgehend französisch
[Musik]
fragen ob nicht nach dem spektakulären
Prozess mit seiner Exfrau umstritten sei
tut der Festivalleiter ab ich bin der
Letzte mit dem Sie darüber sprechen
können denn wenn es an den Menschen auf
der Welt gibt der sich nicht
interessiert hat für dieses Verfahren
das in den Medien so verbreitet wurde
dann bin ich das ich interessiere mich
für Johnny Depp den Schauspieler
ein anderer Alter Hollywood Recke wird
ebenfalls sind kann erwartet Harrison
Ford stellt eine neue Ausgabe der
Indiana Jones Reihe vor
[Musik]
derweil äußerte sich die Jury des
Festivals wie sie bei einem anderen
Rennen vorgehen will dem um die Goldene
Palme
manchmal ist eine Stimme in einer Jury
besonders entschieden und alle anderen
folgen dann hinterher ich will so eine
Konsensbildung verhindern jedes Jury
Mitglied soll sich erst einmal frei
aussprechen können
Wim wenn das bringt zwei Filme mit nach
kann einer zeigt Leben und Werk des
Künstlers Anselm Kiefer in die Kinos
kommt er in 3D auch sonst fehlt es ihm
nicht am Tiefe Menschen suchen jetzt
leicht es ist schwerer nicht sehen
wollen den Abgrund nicht den von Grund
auf wollen die Leute das nicht sehen
warum gibt's diese Leichtigkeit zwei
Wochen lang dreht sich rund um das
Festivalgelände in kann nun alles um die
Stars und ihre Filme oder zumindest fast
alles
und die tolle Schauspieler Sandra Hüller
ist auch mit zwei Filmen übrigens dabei
und um 0:30 Uhr ist es nah dran mir die
sich mit unserem heute journal Update
meldet wir sagen tschüss für heute
machen sie es gut wo auch immer Sie sind
und dran bleiben 37 Grad folgt jetzt
[Musik]
guten Abend zum Wetter der
satellitenfilm von heute Mittag zeigt
uns schön dass jetzt aus dem Nordwesten
kühlere Luft zu uns fließt und zwar
erkennen wir das an diesen vielen
einzelnen Schauerwolken das ganze
passiert zwischen einem hoch das ist
dieses wolkenfreie Gebiet hier in
Westeuropa und einem Tief das sich über
der Ostsee einkringelt wir kennen aber
auch sehr schön die Wolken die zu dem
Unwetter tief hier über Mittel Italien
gehören da gibt es ergiebige Regenmengen
zwischen Mittelitalien Kroatien bisschen
nach Ostösterreich und eben auch
Dauerregen bei uns in den Alpen bis
morgen Mittag können oder Regenmengen
von 50 Liter pro Quadratmeter in 24
Stunden fallen und die Schneefallgrenze
singt auf 1.000 m ansonsten ist es heute
Nacht aber weg sind bewölkt und je nach
bewölkerung sinken die Temperaturen auf
7 bis 0 Grad und dann ist vereinzelt in
den Mittelgebirgen schon Bodenfrost
möglich in der Nacht auf Donnerstag also
die nachte da drauf gibt es dann ganz
verbreitet in Deutschland Bodenfrost und
dann schützen Sie am besten ihre
selbstempfindlichen Pflanzen der Tag
morgen der ist auch eher kühl für einen
mai-tag mit 11 Grad an den Küsten 17
Grad gibt es im Rhein-Main-Gebiet und
rund um Berlin etwas kühler ist es noch
an den Alpen hier liegen aber dann auch
die dichten Wolken der Dauerregen lässt
im Tagesverlauf nach ansonsten wechseln
sich Sonne und Wolken ab ein bisschen
unangenehmer oder bisschen mehr Wolken
gibt es an der Nordseeküste mit einem
Bögen nördlichen Wind in den nächsten
Tagen vor allem am Feiertag läuft es
dann meist trocken ab und bis zum
Wochenende steigen die Temperaturen
wieder deutlich an am Samstag gibt es
schon 24 Grad das war es von uns tschüss